Harry
I'm experiencing one-point-eight cheese
right now which means I weigh about 1.8
times while I normally would have been
instructors keep my head front and
center to avoid nausea but all this is
about to change because this is the
European Space Agency's zero-g flight
those are students doing research this
is Neil who's here for my safety
and we're about to go into 3/4 Wow Wow
and here's the confusing thing we are
still going up right now that camera is
stabilized to the actual horizon and
it's not until 10 seconds into our
20-second parabola into our manoeuvre
that we clip the apex and start heading
back down towards the ground and here we
go one point Aging's
Oh in this special area crust we divide
as a three axis speech roll and twist in
each pilot fly one axis so you know
every other aircraft one pirate flight
the three axis and the other one manage
the system talk to the radio and so on
to fly parabolas we need to fly only one
axis by one pilot we try to avoid any
turbulence every turbulence is is a
nightmare for us the two control sticks
just like any plane are completely
locked together so they always move at
the same time so one of the pilots is
using effect of the elastic bands on
either side of his stick so that he
doesn't affect the axis of the other
pilot one of them does the pitch the
other one does the roll whilst trying
not to upset the pitch in 1971 the
Apollo 15 astronauts tested something on
the
the idea that all objects no matter
their weight for the same speed if
there's no air they used a hammer and a
feather and they landed at the same time
but the weird thing is that
internationals had thrown that hammer it
would still up a new football from the
moment it left his club to the mounting
hit the ground the only pawn it is from
the gravity of the moon the maths work
out the same no matter what speed or
direct it's going relative to us that's
what we just did here if it sounds weird
sure but we just proved it we're about
to prove it again every five parable
Resort n parable as we change to
maintains best accuracy of the parabolas
especially on the pitch axis because
it's the most demanding flying
techniques so after five or ten
parabolas you are so tired and you have
to to go on your own another less
demanding axis
this parabolic maneuver isn't the normal
kind of thing that you do in an Airbus
and the software in this plane hasn't
been modified because to do so would be
a huge effort to wreak wala Phi it so
with the normal software you have the
normal alarm saying this doesn't seem
like a very good idea guys and one of
the pilots there isn't too busy on the
other two axes is turning off the alarms
that we don't need to worry about and
keeping track are the ones that we might
need to worry about
so those pilots are keeping us on the
exact path that an object would take if
you hurl it into the sky at hundreds of
kilometres an hour and there was no air
though giving us this little protective
bubble of zero-g to fly around it
there is no terminal velocity here only
the design limitations of the plane
we're gonna hit those pretty soon along
with something else because when you're
descending this fast towards the ground
the earth approach is pretty quickly
Thank You Neil if you're a masters or
PhD student from an ISA member state and
you want to be one of the people back
there then have a look at the fly your
thesis program the link is in the
description haha Thank You Neil